this holiday weekend Joe Biden
continuing his virtual campaign from the
basement of his Delaware home meanwhile
president Trump's campaign plans to fly
Ariel keep America great banners over US
beaches so who's got the winning
strategy let's bring in Fox News
contributor and former GOP presidential
candidate and Governor Mike Huckabee
Mike tell us it what do you make I've
got to go to this Biden thing because
really this is not the first time it is
obviously the continued ability to make
these gifts but now for the first time
he's being called on it by
representatives of the african-american
community for his mistakes but yet Biden
continues from the basement to say he's
going to win you know I think Joe's
basement campaign is somewhat maybe
symptomatic of his whole approach to
being president if he were to be elected
we'd all be in the basement I mean
that's the problem with Joe this is a
guy who has spent the last several
months in the basement I just saw a
commercial yesterday Joan Lunden was
talking about a place for Joe it's where
you put all your cranky relatives down
in the basement and keep him out of
sight because every time he surfaces and
it's kind of like you know pucks tetani
Phil the groundhog he comes out sees his
shadow makes a gap and then spends the
next three days with he and his staff
apologizing for what he said so he's
better off just sending some written
messages are learning to have someone do
his voice and let him lip-sync because
when he goes just off the script it's
disastrous as we've seen this week
governor what do you make of President
Trump talking about you know the
reopening of churches and saying that
he's willing to override governor's who
don't allow these places of worship to
open this weekend there's a lot of talk
about whether he would even be able to
do that but what do you make of his
statement about his willingness to do so
well how grateful I am for a president
who recognizes the First Amendment of
the Constitution that gives Americans
two basic fundamental freedoms and says
the
government can't stop it one is peaceful
assembly the other is freedom of
religion he has taken an affirmative
stance for both he's also recognized
that it's ridiculous for some of these
blue state governors to say that you can
go have an abortion but you can't go
have prayer that you can go to a big box
store walk around hundreds of total
strangers rub shoulders with them with
or without masks but you can't go to a
church that's been very careful in
trying to make sure they're people of
social distance the doors are left open
so you don't touch door handles all of
the things that churches are doing but
people need their spiritual guidance
they need a sense of purpose and they
get that from church I would contend
that church is giving people a far
greater sense of life than maybe going
to a supermarket would certainly certain
things have to be purchased but the
president is doing the right thing as to
whether he can order the governor's that
here's how the only way I know he could
do it would be that he would have the
Justice Department demand that they
simply required and filed lawsuit
against any governor or any local
community that says that they cannot
open a church if they're opening
everything else because the fact is that
shows religious discrimination that's
not allowed and I think the president
would be within his rights to SiC the
DOJ on it well you're certainly right I
was at a grocery store yesterday
governor it was not life-giving it was
soul-crushing
okay I think a lot of people are ready
for those churches to be open to
congregate with fellow worshippers but I
want to ask about a tough story we heard
this morning one of your friends friends
of many of us Alan West was in a
motorcycle accident and you're calling
for prayers this morning you know Alan
West is a dear friend I love him I so
respect him like you
he's a combat veteran he put on the
uniform of this country he went and
served he put his life at risk and today
you know he's struggling and coming
through the aftermath of a motorcycle
accident near Waco Texas yesterday still
waiting on word this morning of any
update in the condition he was stable
last night let's pray that he has full
recovery he's running for the chairman
of the Republican
aarti of Texas I just think he's one of
the great Patriots of our time and I
know that all the Fox and Friends
viewers join me in praying for his full
recovery lieutenant Carl Allen West the
great American I know we will be joining
you in thoughts and prayers for him
today governor real quick your Memorial
Day message let's not forget why we have
this holiday let's enjoy it enjoy the
beaches the the lakes the parks all the
things the barbecues but as you
celebrate freedom remember that it was
not free to hundreds of thousands of
people who gave their lives for us to
have this freedom let's cherish it
protect it and pass it on to the next
generation amen
well said governor Mike thank you thank
you very much appreciate your time
always thank you